Hey it's me, Destin,
welcome back to Smarter Every Day.
In one of the previous episodes, we shot a 22 caliber bullet against various Prince Rupert's Drops
and you saw it splatter against the glass
it was fascinating.
Now a lot of people had comments on that, and they said that the problem was the lead would just splash against the glass, it didn't hold itself together.
Instead of doing what we did last time, which was a .22 long rifle bullet which was about 36 grains, going about 1,200 feet per second,
this time we're going to do this. It's a .22 Magnum bullet, I am bad at this, it is a 40 grain bullet, but it's going 1,875 feet per second, which is much, much faster.
In my mind, the most important thing about this, is that it's a full metal jacket, meaning it shouldn't splatter like the .22 lead bullet did
It should hold itself together and impart more of that momentum to the Prince Rupert's drop.
Anyway, if that doesn't work, then the other pistol that I have handy is this, my .38 special
.38 special is a much, much larger bullet.
I know everybody wants me to do the .50 BMG, but I want to step this up incrementally
because I wanna find out where the point of breaking a Prince Rupert's drop is.
So, I don't know if this is going to work but I have a 22 Magnum
the last time I did the shot was with a .22
wtih just the lead bullet now we have a
full metal jacket so I'm going to shoot
the Prince Rupert's drop if I can get it
in the right spot and see if the Prince
Rupert's drop will beat that
here we go
What!? What? All right that was a full metal, that was
a .22 Magnum what on earth
okay
look at that they're tougher than I
thought okay we used a .22 Magnum last
time now we're going to do a .38 special
that was a Full Metal Jacket this is
going to be a full metal jacket you can
see that this particular Prince Rupert's
drop doesn't have a bubble in it and
that's atypical so I'm wondering if that
makes it stronger this is definitely
going to break because it's got a long
tail the question is if it breaks at
impact or if it breaks because of the tail
moving like we've seen before yes
oh no way no way oh shut up
please say you triggered oh god okay okay
dude it just took a .38 special all right
we just lost light so we can't do
another one today
that's absolutely ridiculous that might be
the best slow motion I've ever captured
I think it's stronger because
there's not an air bubble in it at all
and that's atypical we can see instead
of an air bubble it pulled in the outer
edge there, pulled in the outside this
is a special one you know the only place
to go here is higher caliber so we'll do
a .223 and AK-47 in the next video
(drop it, drop it) okay I hope you enjoyed
this episode of Smarter Every Day
obviously we can't rest here I'm going
to do this with bigger guns next video
pretty soon it's going to happen. Anyway -
I want to say thanks to the sponsor
which is Casper.com. Casper makes
mattresses and my wife told me years ago
that we were going to get a Casper and
once we did that they've been sponsoring
ever since. [Laughter] That stays, please say it
was in frame -- all right Casper ships the
mattress directly to your house
so you're circumventing the whole like
you know store taking money off of you
process okay this is a really
high-quality mattress we've had one for
several years when it was time to get
one for the guest bedroom we decided to
do it because we liked the feel of it
this is the fun part
it's vacuum sealed you hear it oh wow
okay it's that simple if you don't check
out a Casper mattress you can go to
Casper.com/smarter you can get a
100 night free trial and if you don't like it
they'll come get it it's memory foam we
really like it. Will they like it? Oh yeah
we like ours we're not just trying to
sell you stuff and it molds to you it's
slightly firm, and whenever you get out of
bed at night
or come into bed at 2 AM I don't
ever feel it not that I'd ever do
that right anyway go to Casper.com/smarter
if you want to support Smarter
Every Day we'd really appreciate it
and you'll like the mattress you really will.
Alright I hope you enjoyed
this video and I hope it earned your
subscription because next time I'm doing
the AK and my mini-14 I don't have an
AR I'm a I'm a cheap gun kind of guy
anyway I hope you love this video
because I really want to find the point
at which a bullet beats the Prince
Rupert's drop I know everybody wants me
to do a BMG .50 Cal but I'm not going to
do it I'm going to walk up slowly and
find the point at which a bullet beats a
Prince Rupert's drop because I really
want to know
drop it good girl alright you ready in
the water yeah do it could do it oh man
what do you do alright so please feel
free to subscribe because I would really
like to see you on that next video if
not no big deal thank you to everyone
who supports on patreon it makes this
kind of goofy stuff possible really
appreciate it bye throw it yeah do it.
I should say thank you for helping, I really
appreciate, you didn't expect to get roped
into this I don't think. Or flossed into it.
Haha flossed into this. Oh that's neat, it's a
fiberoptic I can remove my hand oh
that's cool you can see my hand when I
move my hand it's gone that's neat